so the other day I was watching Shang
Chi and I was so
oh my God why did you do
like the way you delivered
so the other day
so yeah
so
so the other day I was watching shangshi
and I was so impressed by the fight
seconds on the bus and how they were
able to make it feel so visceral and
real without actually hurting anybody I
know the punches and kicks aren't real
but they feel real and I wanted to know
how they did it so I made a call I'm a
second unit director and stunt
coordinator that's Wade Eastwood no
relation to other Hollywood eastwoods
he's worked on some of the great action
movies of the past decade and you can
see him right there in 2008's Quantum of
Solace as Daniel Craig stunt double
before Wade even takes a step on set he
and his team will do a ton of prep and
pre-visualization you might be familiar
with VFX previous thanks to Marvel these
are the Lo-Fi animations they do in
advance of making the movie but
oftentimes stunt teams will do action
Biz I shoot it live you know with the
broken cameras action viz often looks
more like this sets are made of boxes
and stuntmen play the lead roles as they
figure out all the action in the camera
angles in his safe space then when it
comes time to shoot the movie the main
unit would shoot the drama and the
acting scenes and then I would shoot
everything action wise with my unit
let's break a fight down to its most
basic element like a punch how do you
sell a good
both sides have to work the a side and
the B side but the person throwing a
stun punch throws it with a you know the
best movement and performance you can
have for the person receiving it does a
really lame reaction it doesn't work
both parties have to give a hundred
percent this is important because the
actors in The Stunt people generally
aren't actually hitting each other
which can look fake if you're not
stacking the action which is the cool
industry term for saying that the people
in the punching need to be layered in a
way that cheats the camera if
we're not stacking the action obviously
you can see it as a distance it's not a
cell if I'm here suddenly I need to have
punch and I'll react it can come across
so we have the same Gap it's just where
we put the camera it's a couple of
inches it's you know maybe a foot Max
depending on what it is sometimes though
as Michael B Jordan explained on The
Graham Norton Show you have to actually
make contact to sell it when you do
slow-mo shots you can't fake it you
would see the space and it just wouldn't
It wouldn't connect this is Michael B
Jordan taking a real person yeah and
action
the B side of a hit aka the person
getting hit has all the power in terms
of selling how hard a punch should be so
a small hit might leave me unfazed but
if I get hit
so if I pull to the ground it looks a
lot more powerful but knowing how to
fall correctly and safely is a whole
skill on its own if you watch a big car
crash the kinetic energy is breaking
down throughout the whole mood if that
car hits a wall and stops dead the
driver inside would be dead because your
body cannot withstand that much impact
and that's really the thing with falling
you've got to just do just enough the
poor arm might just absorb a little bit
before the shoulder does before the back
does before the whole body is and it's
five percent five percent five percent
and making sure that you make it look
really gnarly but you're actually it's
not that gnarly although obviously
sometimes you are going to hurt yourself
bruise yourself proper rib you are going
to do something
but that can be mitigated with
strategically hidden padding which you
can see right here in this scene from
Atomic blonde though these stairs are
supposed to look like marble or concrete
this Bend indicates that it's a much
safer and softer material I use quite a
lot of soft materials where I can I'll
have art Department make something look
exactly like wood or concrete whatever
it is and if we didn't have the padding
we'd do one or two takes it'll be really
painful and you'd probably wouldn't hit
hit it as hard so we put a little bit of
high density absorption in that and you
can hit it much harder and you can do
multiple takes and for that brief moment
the audience get to live that hard
impact with you
and once that fight goes into
post-production there are even more
tricks used to make it look like the
hits are just a little bit harder like
that hit looks pretty hard but if you
cut out the frame where the fist is
supposed to make contact your brain will
fill in the Gap and it'll look like
there's just a bit more power to that
hit you can see this trick used in this
shot from Shang Chi where simu lose
elbow pops on impact you can also do
things where visual effects can slightly
we don't do it but a lot of movies do
where you can extend the fist
and actually make it hit the face you
can see a good example of this in this
clip from no time to die where the VFX
team gave Anna to armas digital legs and
they pulled the stunt guy in slightly
closer to get more energy out of the hit
and of course the sound design of a
fight scene can add clarity as to when a
swing misses or hits
an out of the scene completely
you wouldn't as easily be able to tell
how softened the blocked kick feels or
how bone shatteringly hard a punch feels
no matter how cool a fight looks it
won't feel exciting if there's no Stakes
while I love The Avengers movies some of
the scenes where they're just tearing
through an army of bad guys kind of
washes over me a little bit but then you
have something like Back to the Future
where the whole movie builds to this one
punch that changes the course of history
there's a lot of fights that are out
there that I've you know great
spectacles of fights but if you look at
why are they fighting or what it's about
it's not there's not really any Rhyme or
Reason but when it's a proper fight a
proper Journey a proper you know a bit
of emotion that is when a fight feels
exciting
that is when a fight feels exciting
how's that oh God no
well were you impressed by huh
I was watching chunky
I was looking you two dead in the eyes
yeah
sorry
I'm laughing I can't see me right
was that like two I feel like that was
maybe too silly on the delivery sorry
but
all right I think that's a wrap